كانت شركه المالكه للفيسبوك وانستجرام قصه
الاسواق في العام الماضي بعد هبوط بنسبه
تجاوزت السبعين في المئه المشكله الاكبر
كانت المنافسه من تيك توك ومنصات اخرى
والقبضات السريعه لشركات الذكاء الاصطناعي
مثل
لكن يبدو ان مثل نفضت الغبار عن عام 20 22
وتدخل السنه الجديده بخطه ضخمه على العنف
باسم عشرين ثلاثه وعشرين سنه مكافاه تراهن
متى على استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي لتتفوق
على منافساتها تيك توك التي تمكنت من سحب
جمهور كبير من متى بفضل استخدامها المبتكر
بتقنيات
تيك توك سحبت ايضا مما جزءا مهما من
الاعلانات ما ساهم في تراجعها حيث انخفضت
حصه متى الملكه لجوجل الى 50% من
الاعلانات الرقميه لاول مره منذ عام 2014
ووضعت متى تحديا في هذه الانظمه لتحسين
انظمه استهداف الاعلانات مستخدمه
الاصطناعي لاعاده جزء من المعلنين الذين
خسرتهم ومعناها طردت احد عشر الف موظف
العام الماضي ضمن حمله في السيليكون فالي
لتخفيض النفقات في الركود الى ان
خطه مقلصه تكاليف بشكل صارم في هذه السنه
بنحو خمسه مليارات دولار وتبدو متى مقتنعه
بادائها المستقبلي حيث اعلنت ايضا عن
شرائها لاسهمها باربعين مليار دولار حصيله
هذه الخطه ترجمه عن
مستثم بالسهم بنسبه 19% فهل نحن امام مشهد
مختلف متى ومنطتيها فيسبوك وانستجرام